i think when you once you treat your
hobby like a job
uh that's like a recipe for failure and
that's what happens to a lot of people
yeah i feel like i can rule the world i
know i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
my days
all right what's going on what's up man
so we're gonna get
into some ideas but let me tell you
something that i did this week and i
cannot
give the i actually got in trouble three
different times where someone was like
hey we had this conversation
and you just talked well
i'm like well i don't i just when you
and i
the way that you and i talk now is how
we talk all the time yeah
and yeah and they're so they're right so
i'm going to try to keep this one vague
i had this dinner and i was with the guy
who has 8 000
employees in china as well as many
thousand in america
wow and yeah impressive person like a
factory or
something else in china tech related
just like just some huge company you
if i gave you 100 guesses you likely
wouldn't guess it it's just some big
company that exists
and in the tech world fair enough and um
it's impressive but it's not like
a mainstream thing okay and there was
this other guy there who
made a comment where he was like china's
gonna crush us in the next
five years or something and then a
couple other people people love to say
that by the way don't people love saying
how china's
passed up america a bunch of other
people
pounced on that and then this guy it was
this guy he lives in china
um i believe he he he i don't know what
ethnicity he was but he looked like he i
mean he's probably maybe born and raised
in china and then there's this other
woman there
who actually was born and raised in
china and this guy with the 6 000
chinese employees goes a lot of people
say that
i do not think that's true and i don't
think any of you should ever think that
uh he was just saying he was like
americans actually work
maybe as hard or harder than a lot of
other countries
interesting um and also you talk about
this like artificial intelligence and
this um
it's mostly ai that people i mean they
talk about china crushing america and a
bunch of stuff but ai is like a hot
thing and this guy was like i don't
think that would happen and if
and what i think you should do is invest
all most of your money into american
uh equities i think he goes like i'm
just so bullish on america
and this so it was like an interesting
perspective have you ever heard that
it's like the one person who
probably knows what they're talking
about at the table and everybody else
who just reads [__] on twitter
and like regurgitates it uh all right
i'm gonna go with the guy who's got six
thousand employees in china that that
makes more sense to me
that's you know and and that was good i
felt great about that
and so uh it was just an interesting
perspective but
we love you some pro-america
news yeah well so i'm also just finished
reading this really great book
uh do you know who giant steinbeck is no
of course you do grapes or wrath no what
is that
[Laughter]
i got a blank here wow uh have you heard
a kill of mockingbird
i have heard to kill mockery that's the
author oh my god like john cyber i mean
people are going to make fun of you by
the way anyway and mostly just read
harry potter okay like it let's
be clear this guy he was born in 1902
so he's dead he's probably died in the
70s but anyway i'm reading this great
book about
his memoir from driving across the
country for three months in america
and getting to know america and it's
really funny in 1965 when he was doing
this trip he was complaining about how
americans are getting out of touch with
and are getting too focused on
technology and how there's refrigerators
everywhere and there's tvs everywhere
and how there's artificial food
everywhere
it's very funny we've always complained
about this stuff but
i do love learning about america i think
america's special
i think we have this research resilience
and i think the yeah anyway i'm very
pro-america so yes i did like hearing it
but you want to talk about some ideas uh
yeah by the way dan corrected us i don't
think he wrote
to kill a mockingbird but no of man or
something
he he he didn't write to kill a
mockingbird i'm saying
his work is like it's like it's it's
like
did he write mice and men i know he
wrote like grapes of wrath it's just
like a famous like american classic i'm
just shocked
the fact that you don't know that he
wrote of mice and men so you know that
so the fact that you you by the way i
know that as in i've heard those words
before that's all i know about that
anyways let's
let's go into the stuff i do know about
because i feel a lot better about that
and also
bitcoin rally thank you i've been
waiting for this bitcoin pump and here
we are we're back up
life is good because bitcoin is now
right it's like spiked up to almost 40
000 uh over the last like 24 hours 48
hours
there was a bit of a short squeeze about
a billion dollars of short positions
got liquidated and that caused the price
to uh run up because
um are you familiar with how that works
by the way like what a short squeeze is
like
so no so here's the like non-technical
non-super uh super like
nuanced version of it basically when you
have a short you're betting against
something
and if it goes up you are on the hook to
pay
the the sort of the price for the for
being wrong
and so if you think something's gonna
keep going up
you're better out just closing down your
short position just taking the l
and saying okay i'll pay i'll i will i
will go buy the shares now
because i'm you know let's say i was
it's at 30 000 i think it's going down
it goes to 32. you know what to close
out my position i'll go buy the
asset at 32 and i'll eat the loss right
um
but what happens is because all the
shorts start worrying that the price is
gonna run up
they all start trying to close out their
positions at the same time so they all
start buying so
the people who are betting against it
all of a sudden at all this buying
pressure
where they have to to close out their
position they have to buy bitcoin
which causes the price to go up and up
and up and up and so
what happened is as it started running
up all the shorts had to cover their
positions because they were massively
leveraged right they're not putting in
their own money they're putting in like
five to ten percent
down and they're taking the they're
taking 10x or 20x
leverage on their position so as the
price goes up they're very sensitive to
it
and so i think that's what happened uh
to cause the price to go up about ten
thousand dollars
in the last two days is those shorts had
to cover their position this is what
happened with tesla
tesla was the most shorted stock in the
stock exchange
and then as the price started to go up
those shorts
you know they basically are paying a
huge price for every
every dollar it goes up so they start to
close out their positions which
which puts a bunch of buying pressure
which is why it becomes a squeeze
because the shorts themselves
cause the other shorts to like have to
cover and it just causes the price to
shoot up
way above what its earnings is and
anything else
dude this is funny it's funny because
like when you you do so we're in this
chat group
sean and me and all a bunch of other
like successful young guys and they talk
about like
alpha like crushing alpha and i'm like i
don't know what that means
yeah i got no idea what that means we
talk about short squeeze i'm like this
these words don't mean anything to me i
don't even know what they mean
you guys feel like so sophisticated to
me yeah um
all right let's talk about some ideas
can we yeah let's do it you want to go
or you want me to go
you go first okay i have one okay here's
another one that's crypto related and
you're going to be like what
uh but i'm telling you this is a good
idea this is actually ben's idea so
first of all ben is visiting me
so i'm getting to see ben in person he's
sitting five feet away from me i wanted
him to join this but
had so many goddamn technical
difficulties setting up that like i
don't know how
i could get it to be where it works but
maybe wednesday
we'll take an extra hour beforehand and
just get it set up for a two-person
setup
um but anyways ben ben were talking last
night and he's like you know one
we're talking about courses right
because and i could share kind of like
how what the numbers
like i just finished my course i can
share what the numbers were on that but
we were talking about other few other
potential courses we could do like what
would be fun
he's like i don't know he's like we're
not the right people to teach this but i
think this course with crush right now
so sam tell me do you know what solidity
is if i say oh
solidity so no when i saw you writing i
thought i thought it was a typo for
solidarity right solidarity is what
we'll call it
so solidity is the programming language
that you use to write smart contracts
for ethereum so let's say uh like one of
the most promising things about crypto
is that you can write a smart contract
so think like
a basic escrow contract i buy a house
you're going to give me the title i'm
going to give you the money
but i don't want to give you the money
first you don't want to give me the
title first so we use this third party
this escrow agent we pay them five
thousand dollars
basically you hand them the title i hand
them the money they say yep they're both
here
and then they give it to each other
right so in the real world we paid these
exorbitant middleman fees i don't know
what you paid for your house when you
when you bought it or you just did
another real estate transaction i don't
know what you're paying for escrow i
don't even i didn't even look at it i
don't know it was like
four grand to do an escrow transaction
which sucked i was like this is just
for nothing when i sold my business i
think the escrow was fifty thousand
dollars
right crazy they think this is crazy so
and they literally do like one ounce of
work
um they literally just oh you hand me
the title and you hand me the money
great i'm gonna just
turn one hand over here and i'll give
you the you'll give you this i'll give
them that
so a smart contract basically says look
we don't need this like
person in the middle and we don't need
to pay them four thousand dollars let's
just make a contract with some rules and
we'll just instead of writing it
like a lawyer contract we'll write it
like a programmer contract the
programmer contract says
hey when this wallet has this much money
in it
person a has fulfilled their obligation
and when this wallet has this asset in
it person b has fulfilled the obligation
and then release
the assets to each other um and so and
instead of paying four thousand dollars
you can pay four dollars or forty
dollars whatever the gas fees are at the
time
so that's smart contracts so what
what that means is a lot of jobs today
that go to lawyers are going to go to
programmers
because you're not going to want a
lawyer to write a contract for something
you're going to want a programmer to
write it down
but you need that contract to like work
it needs to be like solid bug proof
hack proof and like i needed to do the
many things that i need my
my transactions to do so there is an
extreme
shortage right now of smart contract
developers
of developers who know how to write in
this new programming language and write
these types of contracts
but it's clearly like a big part of the
future in my opinion
and so one idea here is to create
basically a boot camp that takes an
existing engineer and says hey cool
oh you write javascript or like you know
you're
you're a back-end engineer you're one of
like 10 million
um why don't you come over here where
there's this high demand high shortage
of engineers that know how to do this
thing i can train you in six weeks
to learn how to write like smart
contracts and solidity
and then go to all the companies that
are trying to hire this and basically do
a lambda school
i think you can do a lambda school
that's really niche really focused and
if i'm an engineer that like
i'm a crypto nerd this is a business
that i think you could do you can just
train other engineers
to like learn how to write smart
contracts and then get hired and placed
in these jobs that you take the
placement fee what do you think of that
so i'm doing research while you're
talking all right oh
wow okay no i i agree with a lot that
you said except for the last part
so there's this company called coursera
have you heard of coursera
of course um so they were starting 2012
and i believe that they were started
because the two guys i think they worked
at google
and they're noticing that we are
struggling to hire a particular type of
engineer i'm just this is just off
memory so i might be a little bit off
here about some of the stuff
but anyway they uh and so they built
like these courses
and they built it so people can get jobs
at google
data science or machine learning or
something yeah it was some type of data
science or machine learning i forget
exactly what it was
and they they came out of the gate and
they crushed it and then
like over the last five years they kind
of like went nowhere and kind of like it
was like what the hell happened to that
company and they're not really doing
that well anymore
well over the last year and a half two
years with cove and a bunch of other
stuff they started crushing it
do you know what uh coursera's revenue
is now no idea
so they uh they went public did you know
that no
yeah a lot of people didn't know we
didn't talk about they had like
stagnated and like wasn't going anywhere
yeah that's what everyone thought so in
2020 they did about 300 million dollars
or sorry
my bad 400 million dollars in revenue
and they're currently publicly traded at
a five and a half billion dollar
valuation
and wow yeah crazy right totally forgot
about it and
what you did with your course well i
don't know if you did this but
what a lot of people and like you and me
we'll do courses and we'll kind of do
these kind of like bootleg things not
bootleg but like
yeah yeah and you'll charge like
three hundred dollars or something like
that which i've done before
and that makes things a little bit and
you want like a person to buy it and
that thing
makes things a little bit challenging
what i would do is i would take the
thing that you're describing
and with this with bitcoin there's like
all these crazy new things that you've
got to learn really quickly i would just
copy the coursera model and just churn
these [__] out
and charge like eight thousand dollars
and it's like
we're gonna like a company needs to buy
in order to train their people
so i think that's lambda for x i would
do coursera for x
okay i think that's fair the thing with
the lambda side
which is basically i think every time
you place one of these engineers that's
like a 20 to 25 000
fee that you get and so it doesn't take
much to be
i don't i wouldn't do this as like a
venture scale business not at all this
is basically
i'm a developer who you have to be the
right mold it's like
i've been tinkering with smart contracts
for the last two years anyways
i've actually kind of like gotten up to
speed myself i'm a converted back-end
engineer who now does smart contracts
and i could go i work at like a fang
company today i make 400 000
like wouldn't it be great to make like
four million dollars a year and i think
this is a way to make four million
dollars a year as like
a two-person company basically that's
why i agree yeah
i would never do it in the land so when
sean says lambda school he's referring
to it's free
and you make money by getting like a 25
referral placement or a percentage of
their income salary
i have i know nothing about lambda other
than we had austin on the show and i
think he's amazing and i love him
and you're an investor that's really all
i know about it i think
my prediction if i had to bet money on
it is that it won't work
yeah i think that's a i mean i think
that's a fair prediction about most
startups i think that's true
uh well yeah but they're not most
startups they've raised like 100 million
dollars probably they're not like an
early stage startup they're like in the
thick of it
i think that if they're out of business
in two years i wouldn't be surprised
right
and i would agree with that even as a
fan and an investor i would agree with
that
um i think that okay so here's okay let
me do two things
first let me share with you a really
hilarious story do you know this twitter
account
greg it's like greg nine five five three
two three like three two six seven
eight seven a white guy like like a
white old guy it's a white no not old
guy it's a white like nerdy
dork guy no i don't know so
you haven't seen this just google search
greg meme
uh greg meme account uh you'll see it
and i bet you've seen this guy so
you know like these mimo castle there's
like dr park patel
by the way big fan of him i think he's a
big fan of us
uh he works for the hustle you know that
right doctor park patel works with the
hustle
yeah oh my god you just outed dr park
patel amazing
no no no no no no he like him
he's a contractor for us he writes for
us sometimes oh my god i love it
wow no i did not know that yeah yeah
yeah
my brain is racing to figure it out who
it is now okay
no he's not like like i was a fan of his
and i dm'd him and i was like hey
you don't know the real identity uh i do
okay you do but it's yeah so you're
saying yeah after you saw a dark fire so
then you contracted okay gotcha
makes way more sense so anyways what he
one thing he does is like every time
chamath tweets
he's like the first reply and he's like
just says it like
like i'm proud of you son or something
like that like something like totally
non-standard
so greg does that with like kylie jenner
and like other people like that where
every time she posts something he'll be
like babe why did you like
you didn't call me or like it's like
we're like i'm so proud of you babe
so it's like as if they're dating and so
he's this like dorky looking white guy
account
and uh so the other day do you know who
jose canseco is
of course ben told me the story so so
jose canseco the base former baseball
player tweets out
i need a i need a smart contract
developer for a new token a token
developer for a new token i'm going to
launch
this which is like the classic thing for
like paris hilton and
joseph
has been celebrities that are like ready
to launch their own crypto token here we
go that what could go wrong
so so greg replies and greg's like
uh like whatever like me ben what did he
say
what was his reply was it just like pick
me something like that
oh yeah he goes hey it's greg dm me how
can i help
and jose replies and goes um
he goes awesome like are you a token
developer
and then like are you are you developer
or smartphone can you know how to do
token development
i think greg just replies no way jose
200 000 likes on that tweet it's just
like one of the most liked tweets on
twitter
this is like so good so dumb uh but
anyways this guy's like crushing it
right now like he's got like a hundred
and something hundred
thirty years handle well it's the funny
thing is
you know when you sign up for twitter
let's say you typed sam it'd be like
sam's not available
would you like sam eight hundred
thousand and six because that's like the
next one available
so his is greg and then it's like 12
numbers that are like
the whatever the default thing would be
so it's like you would never think it's
gonna go viral yeah it's greg one six
six
seven six whatever like you know like 10
numbers long
so what does this have to do though with
okay so that was just my smart
contract uh token developer uh tangent
my next idea if you're ready to
transition i am is
is um unbundling a piece of yc
so yc does a few things for founders yc
puts a stamp on you it says this is a yc
startup so all of a sudden your
valuation's gonna go up blah blah
they kind of coach you so they say oh
you know come in for office hours tell
us about your idea maybe we help you
pivot your idea maybe we
help you stay focused on growth or you
know how to like tweak it so you grow
faster and they do that for three months
and then
then they start working on your pitch
and then there's demo day which is like
where you're gonna get to stand in front
of investors you've got to give a one
minute pitch you're gonna raise money
that works they have like whatever 120
startups a year now or something doing
that
um but another another kind of like
course quote-unquote court i'm very i
was brainstorming i was like very
interested working backwards from what's
a course where
the person gets a clear outcome this is
part of my learnings of like
doing a course which is people don't buy
a course for learning
they buy some change they buy a
transformation for themselves
and so like you know for a startup going
from unfunded to funded or like
you know no name to like oh stamp of
approval that's like actually a big
change
and so one one transformation and one
change that people would buy
is getting their first round of funding
it's like i'm not just going to teach
you
knowledge that you can may or may not
use it's like
i'm going to help you get funded and so
i was thinking could you like
i've raised probably 20 million dollars
in my life and i've helped a bunch of
founders raise money
and i think i'm pretty good at
storytelling so i was like i think i
could help
a founder who's got no no funding today
get funding
in like a one month period and i think i
could basically just sit you down with
the deck
with your story and then basically say
cool like
there's a pretty intense workshopping of
your deck and your story to get that to
be as good as it's gonna be
and then there's like a bunch of angel
like introductions and like teaching you
how to manage your pipeline so that you
run this like a process like a bidding
war
unlike what most people do which is they
kind of try to date one investor at a
time and they go kind of slow and they
fear rejection and they don't know how
to reach out and all this stuff i can
teach you that kind of like the sales
process
of investing and i was thinking i was
like oh you could do this like on a
success basis so
again like lambda which you don't like
but uh honestly you could align your
incentives which is by the way i like
lambda i just think the business model
is silly
i think because the thing with education
is that
most people will never benefit from what
you're telling them
right well that's the in some ways
that's the beauty of lambda but it's
also the bad side of lambda right the
beauty of lambda is
their incentive is aligned so let's say
most courses like let's say for my
writing course
i don't care if you're good at writing
bad at writing and i really don't
truly care if you're gonna do it or not
because i get paid either way right like
i'd love for you to take the course
and have a big benefit but the reality
is like my financial incentive is not
such that
if you don't if you if you don't hit
your goals it doesn't really make a
financial difference to me whereas for
lambda does
they have to select people who are gonna
be able to succeed
and then they only make money when
somebody gets what they want which is a
high paying job
so that's the beauty of lambda but it's
also the hard part about stealing what
what were what were the results from
your course though like
what did that go well uh it went well
so basically okay so here's the kind of
like the learnings from my course all
right so can i guess
can i guess yeah yeah we'll do it on
each category so first is
let's start with the most interesting
one money how much money do you think i
made
doing this course
i taught a course on power writing which
is basically writing to get a result
so like the writing i type i do which is
like if i'm writing an email it's
because i want somebody to reply if i'm
writing a landing page because i want
somebody to click
buy button if i'm writing uh tweet
storms because i want people to share it
and like the stuff you learn in school
is not the stuff that
that actually works in the real world
and so it's like copywriting plus plus
that's the that's the course all right
so i do this 150 is my guess
150 000 very close so i did 127
000 of top line sales and then let's
just break down the the p l so
so then there's my cost of making the
course so i basically had a guide to
like custom illustrations and graphics
and things like that
that would probably be eight to ten
thousand seventy five hundred
um and he was amazing and he was really
good and so i'm like
i loved that that was that was worth it
then there's mavin's fee
uh so maybe the fee is on the top number
so i should take that like 10 10
right so so take out 12 grand roughly
from 127 then you take out 7 500 of
cost production then everything else
then there's payment processing fees
that was another four three or four
grand
and so my net was like 100 i'm doing the
math bad here but i think it was like
roughly um and then okay so so that's
kind of like
that's the the money in and so that was
off of 320 students i charged
the first batch i did at half price so i
charged i think
450 or something like that uh 400 maybe
it was for the for the course
uh and if i had that did you do like an
mps
yes i would bet it was like out of 10
out of 10. so for those who don't know
net promoter score basically you ask one
question to your audience which is
how likely are you to refer this to a
friend on a scale of one to ten ten
being
i you know i absolutely will refer i
would absolutely refer a friend to this
one being no way seven point three
nine 9.1 that's amazing most of
everything is but it's definitely nice
right because
some people didn't reply to the survey
so i'm assuming the people who really
didn't give a [__]
also didn't reply to the survey so i
gave myself a true nps of probably eight
but it was a 9.1 on the the stats so do
you think people loved it
i think people loved it uh the feedback
was kind of amazing
and then i did a survey of like what did
you like about it and basically it broke
into three categories it was like
look i can't you know the first one was
dude two of those sessions were like
like
game changers for me it's like oh you're
a cold emailing one
like that was great i immediately
implemented this and i got you know
meetings that i wanted i
booked more sales like that one i just i
used right away or like the second one
would be like
you have one about writing inside of a
big company how to like stand out with
your writing inside a big company
that was i didn't even know i wanted
that that was a great one and so
everybody kind of had two
of this i did seven sessions everybody
had like two sessions that they were
like
that was the one and the rest was fine
you know like the rest was good but like
didn't really like
those two i got my money's worth the
rest was gravy
um and then i asked people the other
question i asked people was on average
how much value did you get like you know
zero dollars
the price of admission like a 1x return
3x 5x 10x whatever it was
and then the average per the average
answer to that was 10x my money i got
10x my value
back out of it and i was like okay for
what i don't know if that's like a
scientific question because
how the hell are they measuring that i
don't really know but okay
downsides guess what the biggest
downside was because you've done a
course before so
tell me what what do you predict was my
biggest
the biggest downside of it uh well does
that include logistics like
quality like so i think they'll probably
complain about your camera
or your sound or the time uh
yeah timing was the biggest one because
i taught it live
and so a lot of people you know were
like oh you know i could i either
the time worked great for me it worked
okay for me or it was horrible for me
because i'm in australia and that time
zone was awful
uh so i only watched the recordings the
the i went the biggest complaint i had
to do the voice what was the biggest
downside of doing the course
talk too fast no no i mean like why
what was the pain in the ass for me well
it's probably just way too much work
yes complete underestimation of the work
yeah it's so much work i spent probably
50 to 100 hours like making the content
which was way more than i thought i
would do i thought it would take me so
much work
an hour or two per session all right so
let's say two hours per second that's
like 15 hours of work
it was like a full day it was like an
eight hour day per per
session i made plus like the actual
teaching of it and then afterwards what
i would do is
so i structured my the one the best
thing i did by the way was
i think i don't think i invented this
i'm sure other people do this but
i didn't really know what it's called
but i basically structured the session
like this it was like all right you show
up
so it's like hey we're gonna be here for
an hour the very first thing i do is i
say all right the promise is this by the
end of this hour
you're going to be able to do this all
right so that's my problem that's the
magic trick i'm going to show you today
you can't do that or you're bad at it
you're going to be good at it by the end
of this hour
and then i basically would do i'd say
all right let's say it's a cold email
i'm not going to tell you anything about
cold email write a cold email right now
and they would all have to sit there
while i'm sitting there watching them 10
15 minutes write the thing
so it was called do learn redo so i'd
have them do it
i got that gives the bassline and they
would all share it in the slack channel
then i would teach them like not
everything about cold email and be like
hey
here's the three biggest things you
could do to improve your improved cold
emails i do some examples
i teach them the theory and then i'd say
be like all right last 15 minutes you're
going to redo it
and then they would redo it and then
they would just have a before and after
of their
one hour session where it's like a
really shitty first attempt and then
like a pretty good second attempt
and then after the course i would take
one hour and i would just go through as
many examples as i could of students
and just give them like feedback through
loom so that was like
that worked pretty well but it was like
kind of intense for me because i'm
basically performing a magic trick live
i don't know what they're going to do
and so it was kind of high risk it
wasn't like like it could
well are you going to happen my wife did
it by the way sarah my wife did it and
she sold out
she made ten thousand in like two weeks
maybe
and why did she cap it because they told
me to cap it and i didn't care
she's not like you and me this is her
first time doing like a public facing
thing right um you know you and i
have you know tens of thousands of hours
of like riffing under our belt and like
we know how to perform
she she's just learning and trying to
figure out how to do it by the way one
thing you should tell her best thing i
did was i did rehearsals
so for each session i would invite four
kids who are like kind of like
25 and under usually who can't afford
the course and i just say hey you want
the course for free
in a personal session i need to do a dry
run with you and so i did a dry run for
each of the sessions and
in doing that i would realize five
minutes in like
oh this is all [__] up like i gotta
change this or like
wow this is way too hard when i just
asked them to answer
they're confused like they are yeah
yeah so i needed to do those open mics
basically to make it work
but will you do this do you think this
will be a significant income source for
you in the future or are you going to
quit doing it
so i'm doing it one more time we're
going to see how that goes my goal was
basically i put the price back where
the original price so it's 9.50 so i'm
like all right let's see if
there's enough demand there at that
point price point because below that
it's not really worth it for me i don't
think
because you need a lot of students it's
a lot of work so
i'm doing it one more time in august
we'll see if it's like good again i had
a lot of fun doing it so we'll see if
it's fun again or if it gets like old
for me
but then i also have a bunch of other
ideas for other courses that i want to
do so i think i'm going to teach
different
courses which is more work but i think
more fun for me
can i tell you okay so now by the way
we're talking about maven.com
which uh this is here's your disclosure
we both have incredibly
vested interest in this and i want them
to make money yeah because we invested
in them
yeah but i do think they're gonna have
to change i don't think it's gonna work
to do
live courses i don't think are gonna
have they can't be their bread and
butter it's just gotta be
how they get into the market that's
that's my prediction but we'll see
well i started off being like i'm gonna
do it recorded and i started recording
the content
and i found a few people and i was like
uh first of all
recording good content takes a lot of
time too so it's not like it was gonna
save
it saves you time when i you know it's
scalable later but it takes a lot more
time up front
the second thing was people were way
less excited about me
recorded and i was like no no look i'm
like
it's me i'm like planning this out it's
gonna be like as good as i can get it
it's gonna be edited it's gonna be tight
versus me live and they're like no we'd
rather just to be you live off the cuff
and like not
so tight like the perceived value of
live is way higher
and so i was like yeah okay if it's
easier for me to do and it's higher
perceived value like
that was one pivot i had to make halfway
through of like
switching to live um all right let me
let me pivot to a different topic yeah
you maybe told me about this
but i had jake research it i i think you
did you tell me about swimply
yes okay so i like to keep a list of
things that i thought are horrible ideas
and i ended up doing like amazingly well
i definitely would put bitcoin in that
category like you've done like the
stupidest thing i've ever heard of ryan
hoover told me about producthunt the
davey he was launching it and i was like
just quit i also thought it was stupid
yeah yeah um
if you have an easy hack to do this
whenever i just have a bookmark thing on
my chrome
so whenever i see a startup website that
i'm like oh that's interesting
i bookmark it either into i think it's
going to work or i think it's not going
to work
so i have this like then i can go back
like a year later i could just go click
and see how many of those websites are
still like up
and like doing something uh you know and
i exactly
i've had this for like five years so if
i saw this next company that i'm about
to tell you about
in this next idea if i saw that five
years ago or a year ago
i would be like well like just quit why
why are you even doing these stupid
games
like this is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard so it's expensive the name's even
stupid
it's called swim lee is that p supposed
to be there is that a typo
let me see is it swimly it might be
swimly
no it is swimply it's swimly that's it
okay so we're looking at a google doc
that's that's crazy i thought that i
wasn't sure if that was a typo but he
wrote swim please and like everything
the way i found this i was just driving
and i saw a billboard
and it just said swimply rent a swimming
pool near you
and i was like what and that's what it
is so
uh you know with everything going on
people are desperate to get out of their
homes
and they're working from their house and
they want to get out and so they go and
they can
rent someone else's pool airbnb for
pools
if you told me about this four years ago
i'd be like this is the dumbest thing
i've ever
done this is right next to like go out
and rent a dog for an hour
but you're a believer i'm not a believer
yet but the numbers definitely show that
i'm wrong
so they've grown two thousand percent
since summertime and
a roughly fourth that what's so if you
grow four they've grown four thousand
percent
in a year what's that mean forty x
four thousand is forty x yeah okay they
just raised up but you could be on
anything right i could start with one
and get to four that's true but they
raised a series a which i'm shocked and
who's their
they're they're they're they're they're
they're they're they're like they raise
11 or 10 12 million dollars
so so the idea is like i have a pool in
my backyard i can set like a 50
an hour rate and somebody who doesn't
have a swimming pool in the backyard
because that's a big expense can
say cool we'll rent your private we'll
rent your pool we're going to come
swim for two hours 100 bucks there's
four of us it's worth it like we're
gonna have fun doing that
you like kind of clean up your backyard
later um that's the idea
they raise their money from like some
ballers like people who like i think i
respect as knowing what they're doing so
i definitely think i was wrong uh north
northwest ventures they're i mean
they're like a huge
um a huge thing right nor west
generic name come on if you're gonna
figure it out yeah but they're like a
multi-billion dollar
they're big enough that i assume that
they have employee used to like vet
well yeah of course uh okay so their
traffic like
if you look at their similar web thing
it's pretty nuts so like january it's
you know 50 000 visitors and by june
it's like hockey sticking to 400 000
monthly visitors uh according to similar
web so similar web the exact number's
not right but the direction is correct
usually
and so this thing is like doubling it's
like doubled
last month doubled the month before that
doubled the month before that so four
doubles in a row
and so i got i was i was interested in
the space because i found a company
that was raising money and what they
were doing and the reason i got
interested in this company was we had
this guy who i talked about this guy
named preston on the podcast his name
was uh
i don't even remember his last name but
preston i think the company he started
was called spacious
where they would uh do short-term
retail space and rent it out for
co-working yeah there's this other
company that i'll find
i'll say the name in a second and what
they're doing is you can rent
people's homes just during the day for
co-working
oh yeah i've heard of that and it starts
with a c what's it called
cozy or some i don't know what it is
yeah chills
i'm just thinking of names and again
that idea i thought was a stupidest
thing and then i talked to preston and
he's like no these could be legit these
could be huge companies
it's astounding and so here's a few more
companies that
that are interesting so neighbor is a
storage marketplace
and by the way almost all these i would
bet against
and i am being proven wrong consistently
neighbor is a storage marketplace they
just raised a 53 million
series b imove is an electric vehicle
subscription service so you can um
uh they just raised a bunch of money i'm
actually on board with that it's just
like leasing
kazoo subscribe to your next car online
picasa buy
and own a second home with eight others
that's just a time share isn't it yeah
and then resort resort pass you can
share uh
day passes to uh resorts pools and
hotels
so anyway kind of interesting i this
space has always interested me because
i've been the one saying how i think
it's really stupid and it's not gonna
work
but these things are actually are are
beating my
are proving me wrong right uh by the way
a a
you just said something like share a
thing and we're talking about courses uh
we had this idea a long time ago i still
think it's a good idea if somebody wants
to do this
i'll be uh you know first customer slash
your
minority business partner who does
nothing besides give you the idea which
is
class pass for online courses so i right
now would pay
like if you said hey i can bring you a
student
but you're gonna have to you're going to
have to give it to them 50
off but i can get you volume of students
and you don't have to worry about
getting students
um i'd take that and if you basically
i think you can work out the math where
you can basically get
let's call it 100 a month from somebody
and then they get access to like
your course my course sarah's course you
know like 10 other courses right now
um and and get all of them basically
like
and all you can eat past i think there's
a class pass for courses that could work
for online courses
let me um could exist let me keep being
a hater
but there's this company called um every
every dot
what is it called two every dot so or
every dot two
i think every dot two yeah um there's
guys doing that for newsletters and the
guys running it are great uh his name's
nathan
really cool wonderful guy uh i know nat
is a writer there i like his work
there's a bunch of like interesting
uh great writers on there but i think
this business model is
horrible um because dealing with how
you're gonna pay
each writer seems like a huge pain in
the ass doesn't it yeah if i'm like
if i'm like a big shocker based on uh
who brings in subs
so if your stuff brings in a sub you get
the bounty of that you give
i'm bringing in subs like go f yourself
i want to own all of it yeah but you get
you say you get the majority bounty on
yours so let's say you get 50
of the subs you bring in but you're
gonna put 50 of the pool
so you're gonna get 50 from everybody
else and so it's a but the beauty of it
is
when you're doing paid newsletter
there's this obligation like [__] i
gotta write this thing i can't write
one a week i gotta write two a week it's
gotta be good it can't just be like off
the cuff you know random stuff they're
paying for this it's gotta be better
than normal blog content
so what they what every does is say look
you just got to write one good thing a
week let's say
because the consumer is going to get
value from eight other writers in the
bundle
and so that's the that's why this works
is for each person they don't have to
carry the whole subscription
value themselves um they have eight
other people contributing to that
subscription's value
and so just give away some you think
this is going to work
i don't know if it's going to work i
think or the concept at least
yeah i think i think it can work i think
so basically i think
i'm kind of a believer in that that the
mark andreessen
thing that he stole from whoever which
was basically like most business is just
bundling and unbundling
and so i think that right now
newsletters are all unbundled
and somebody creating a bundle of
newsletters it'll be like the cable
package and like
you'll somebody will say uh why am i
paying for i don't want to pay for
10 individual subscriptions and some of
them are good some are bad
and instead if i could just pay a flat
15 a month and get access to
my 10 favorite writers like great so i
think i think it can work
are you getting sick of newsletters uh
no i have fun i like writing my stuff uh
but i i do it on my terms so like i'm
not consistent
i have this thing i send out every
tuesday but like if you subscribe to it
you're like
[__] you don't send it every tuesday
you said it like every other tuesday at
best
and so yeah because i just like if i'm
doing something else that's fun i just
don't send it
and like you've experienced the pain of
my like
my like inconsistencies or being laid
and things like that like
it's just kind of like the way i operate
on all things and like you know
the good the good of it is like when i
do it
like i'm never just going through the
motions like i'm always trying to bring
it
but if i don't have something to bring i
don't like do it or like
sometimes i'm i don't send the thing
because i'm doing something interesting
but that'll make the next week's
letter more interesting because i was
doing something interesting um
so that's my only way of sustaining
these other things i think when you once
you treat your hobby like a job
uh that's like a recipe for failure and
that's what happens to a lot of people
they they think it's fun to blog and
then they want to make that their career
and then you know they make the grave
grave mistake of turning your hobby into
a job
uh when it when you weren't you didn't
want it as a job really
yeah it's hard it's [__] hard as
someone who has
not i haven't written them but i have
owned a newsletter company that has sent
365 newsletters times four years it's
very hard
by the way very challenging i heard uh a
a
another newsletter company that shall
not be named uh say that
oh you know our subscriber base is like
you know the third largest
city in america and i thought that was
just a badass way of saying like we have
whatever two billion subscribers three
million subscribers or whatever it is
uh and i think you should steal that and
start saying things like that
yeah i like that one it's kind of like i
think the skim was the one who said um
the skim said like if we were a morning
show we would be the number one most
popular morning show
right um another great way of framing
that's part of this part of the
playground it's just like [__]
it's a bit [__] but it is yeah it i
it is useful
right um okay do we want we want to wrap
here do we want to go to one more
let's do one more fun thing do you have
one otherwise i can get one
you pick one uh you want to pick one off
your list maybe uh do this elon filing a
patent thing that sounds good
okay so basically i'm working with jake
our researcher to like find different
signals
and figure out what do those signals
mean and so
there's something interesting i've
always been i've always been interested
in gas stations
because like i said we said earlier i'm
like in this nerd about america
i love like nostalgia middle america
stuff
and gas stations are interesting to me
because we spend a lot of time there
like i have found many
memories of gas stations and many of the
biggest top 100 privately owned
businesses in america if you look at one
of the biggest privately owned companies
in america
most not most but a very large
percentage are gas stations
right and so by revenue gas makes up
typically two-thirds of sales
for gas stations but it only makes like
one-third or less of profit
the majority of profit comes from buying
[__] on the inside
and elon musk recently filed a trademark
for different restaurant services aimed
at
electric vehicles and and things like
that and for food services basically
and so i'm very eager to see what
tesla's gonna do
and also i'm very eager to see how the
the modern gas station is gonna change
and
so far so what are the biggest ones i
think the biggest ones are um
are casey's quick trip there's a few
more that are the top ones
they're not doing [__] because if you go
to a gas station right now for
tesla it's still a pain in the butt the
tesla superchargers are way better
and so i'm very eager to see and i
wanted to know what you think
what is going to happen to gas stations
and how are they going to continue
making money
yes i think there's two big changes that
are happening so
cars go electric then what the hell
happens to gas stations
right do they just convert into electric
charging stations or
is it going to be different because
you're charging at home right like i
can't fill up my tank
overnight in my garage but i can charge
my electric vehicle that way and so
maybe those gas stations they're just
not needed anymore they need to convert
some other use of real estate um you
know it's like blockbuster on the corner
store when why would i need that when i
could just push a button and stream
netflix to my tv
the second is self-driving cars which is
going to change
the game for both gas stations and for
um
parking garages so you don't need as
much parking when you have self-driving
cars
most of city real estate is parking
whether it's street parking or parking
garages
there's a huge amount that's just
parking and because cars are idle ninety
percent of the time
when cars go self-driving they're not
going to be idle ninety seven this time
so cities are gonna have to
like re renovate basically the the way
they use their land because it's gonna
become totally obsolete but let's do gas
stations for a second
so one theory is gas stations become
like entertainment hubs because actually
charging a car takes a lot more time
than filling up a gas tank
i think even supercharger takes like 30
minutes right to
to to fill up basically to recharge your
tesla while you're like on a road trip
or whatever
and so you know what what do you do to
entertain people during that time maybe
they're just sitting in their car
using the in in car entertainment system
but maybe there's something else that
you do with food and drink and tvs and
maybe it's a sports bar essentially that
you turn this into
the other thing that i think is
interesting is um
like so i'll give my cousin a shout out
so my cousin rohan has a startup called
stable.auto so check it out
you're not going to fully grok it from
the from the landing page but but i'll
just tell you about it so it says
company stable
uh just stable like s-t-a-b-l-e like a
like a stable of hormones
auto a-a-u-t-o um
so so he started off what he started off
doing was he he
he was like a robotics guy from mit so
he's like look
um how do i make it where a self-driving
car
when it like self-driving cars are gonna
need they're great because they're gonna
drive people around without a driver but
how are they gonna charge
like they have to go to a charging
station and then are you just gonna have
like attendance there plugging in
cars and taking them out like how is it
gonna do that and so he was creating
like
if you've ever seen elon tweeted this
out once um which is a robotic arm that
would just find
the charging thing and would like plug
itself in so it was like a self
a self yeah yeah like as imagine the
gasoline pump could go into your car
without you having to pick it up and put
it in the hole
so he built a robotic arm that did that
so what my cousin was doing was
basically he was just saying oh if
tesla's doing that but then there's all
these companies trying to compete with
tesla
i'll make the robotic arm for all the
other companies
so like every other company has a
different like charging like kind of
like
location on the car how do i make
machine learning that's going to find
the hole and stick the stick in the hole
uh basically for that and he started
doing that but the problem was
and i told him this which was like look
uh
like self-driving cars are not here so
you're building for a future market like
you don't know when it's gonna happen
like
we all know it's gonna happen eventually
like that's a little bit difficult
and so um and so and you're also
building this robotic arm it's really
hard
hard to build so he switched to now he
switched to something else which is
basically like software
that basically will um it it basically
tells you when you need to
when you should go charge your when you
should go charge your electric car
for so imagine like uber and lyft they
have these fleets of electric vehicles
uh that are gonna be out in the roads
and that's for sure happening
and so when do you go charge if you go
wait till you're like almost
out you might miss like peak peak
uh traffic time where you're gonna like
get a bunch of rides and make a bunch of
money
um you also might go charge when it's
really expensive to charge because
electricity costs fluctuate throughout
the day
so what they're building is basically an
app that you load into your like
this is at least last i heard of it it's
like an app for any driver of uber or
lyft that has an electric vehicle that
will say
now is the optimal time to charge go
over here there's a charging station
nearby
there's a little there's not much
traffic for uber rides right now and the
price of electricity is low
and so it basically that'll work while
you have human drivers and then when you
have
self-driving fleets it'll do that whole
thing automatically it'll basically say
hey
let's send to this 10 of your fleet to
go charge right now
let's keep 90 on the road and it'll
optimize it so you're like
saving the most money both ways but
let's talk about
what do you think is going to happen
where's the opportunity right now i i
mean
his idea that maybe i i think it's far
simpler
have you ever heard of bucky's yes
tell people what's bug news do you know
what it is bucky's is basically in texas
there's like a
gas station chain that like people love
they don't just like it they love it
it's a tourist destination and it's
destination for a couple of reasons i
think
i've never been to one even though i
lived in texas it has
extremely clean bathrooms and they have
a bunch of food that people are like
obsessed with
it's basically shitty sugary food
but it has a funny logo and they serve
like
brisket it's just like low quality but
fun it became a thing
yeah but it's huge so i think that it's
gonna break down in two categories the
first categories is just everyday use i
think people are gonna
keep their [__] at home charge at home
or
they're just gonna charge while they're
in the grocery store and that's how they
and that's in whole foods is gonna be
the winner the second thing is
is traveling and i think the way that
that's gonna look is
bucky's it's gonna be just like it's
gonna be a bucky's
meets museum of ice cream so when i go
to bucky's it's a spectacle i stop there
because i'm gonna get like a huge soda
i'm gonna get maybe something to eat but
i'm just gonna look at stupid [__] like
a bucky knife
or a bucky book bag just dumb trinkets
going into a bass pro shop basically
it's like going into a bass pro shop or
just looking walking around ikea it's
just a spectacle
it's gonna be like that with a little
bit of museum of ice cream where there's
gonna be a little bit even more
spectacles that are fun to take pictures
in front of
that is where what's gonna happen i
think and i think like the shells of the
world
or whatever gas station 711
711 i actually think could become a
bucky because 7-eleven
has a little bit of nostalgia like
7-eleven it's kind of it could be cool
it's like subways
yeah yeah it could subway could be could
be uh the next version of vans
yeah um so i think there there's
definitely some people that are gonna go
that route right they make it a tourist
destination
and they have a quirky brand and that
works i think some people are gonna go
full automation so like
in san francisco we had that thing cafe
x did you ever buy coffee from that
no it took too long touch it i mean it
takes like
a minute right it was just stupid i
thought it was dumb
cafe x is stupid how do you think that's
stupid that's like
that's so good so if nobody knows who
look after describe it
so it's basically okay but here's the
thing
so like it's basically a keurig machine
like it's not that fancy but
it looks like it's usually like it's in
a building and it has like this glass
around it and it's a massive
robot arm that's making a spectacle of
like moving the car
the coffee cup around and then pouring
the milk in it in reality
it could like you don't need that stupid
[__] arm it could just be like a
coffee vending machine like i don't so
that's why whenever i saw that i'm like
when i see these like in warehouses and
stuff it's just like you put two
quarters in and you just get like
like at the hospital you've never been
to the hospital to use one of those like
cappuccino machines
like i don't need this dumb [__] arm
to trick me and act like it's doing
something special okay so that's
definitely one way of seeing it and i
i could see that point of view i think
what's the difference between starbucks
and that vending machine is it the
quality of the coffee or what's the
difference
probably not the quality so what is the
one's a spectacle and one you talk to
people
uh no no no so i'm saying like between
the keurig machine and starbucks like
why do you even need a starbucks why
couldn't starbucks just be a curious i
like getting out of the house and
seeing people okay so maybe maybe it's
that if that's the case then starbucks
is safe
the other case is basically that there's
some middle ground of like
variety and quality that's like above a
coffee machine
but more like a starbucks where you have
like 40 drinks that you want because you
want your soy latte
with you know uh you know you want you
want almond milk and then you want two
pumps of sugar and you want
light ice or whatever and like that's
how you like your drink
and so you know you can't get that out
of a cup a normal coffee machine either
the coffee doesn't taste as good or the
drink is not as elaborate
and cafe x basically says cool
what if we could serve coffee faster and
cheaper than a starbucks
what if we could serve starbucks quality
coffee but faster and cheaper than a
starbucks
why because we have a robot arm that
could just like do the thing 24 7
and never call in sick and never be an
employee you never need never have any
employee like issues
and by the way i take up one tenth of
the square footage
of a starbucks because it's like a it's
like a giant robot in a hamster ball
uh it's like it has everything it needs
right there it takes up like
10 square feet wherever yeah it's like
starting by 10. and so what they're
doing with
the idea with cafe i don't think cafe x
specifically is going to succeed
but i'd be shocked if there's not a cafe
x type winner
down the road because you can shove
these things anywhere you can shove it
inside of an apartment building and it
can make sense in apartment building
whereas like a full-service starbucks
with staff
wouldn't make sense in a stu in an
apartment building and so
i think that those are going to succeed
and so i think there's a version of the
gas stations that's like that i think
there's a version of the gas stations
that basically
is just all automation the charging's
automated
and then you go and you push a button
and it creates a giant slurpee for you
like 7-eleven
but it's just a robot arm doing it we'll
see we'll see if it works out but i
think it's gonna be more like buckies
at least i hope it will be um all right
that's the episode
i gotta i gotta go get a haircut
yeah i feel like i can rule the world i
know i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back